[APPLAUSE]
INTERVIEWER: So for anyone who's
not familiar with the
concept of family meal-- who
might just think it's a new
special at McDonald's--
can you tell us what
the definition is?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Well, the term
is used in restaurants.
We don't call it "staff
meal," actually.
I can't tell you where it
started or how it started, but
it's always referred to as
"family meal." Like, the chef
may ask the cook who's
responsible, OK, who's cooking
family today?
Or what do you got
for family today?
And of course, it goes deeper
than that, because we think of
it as a family.
And the very act of cooking this
food, and having everyone
sit down together and enjoy the
food, does create a sense
of family, which is why the book
has a wonderful synergy
with home cooking.
Because that's what you
do in your own home.
INTERVIEWER: And do you feel
that the restaurant always has
this notion of family?
Are there ever incidents in
which that's not the case?
I know in the book, there's a
famous cauliflower anecdote
when you were a stage.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Oh, that
was not our restaurant.
It was in Paris.
Yeah, where a sous chef--
we were sitting
at the table eating.
And the sous chef put a bite of
cauliflower into his mouth
and spit it out.
And we immediately--
things got very quiet.
And he asked who would
cook that food.
And a young apprentice from down
the other of the table
raised his hand.
And the sous chef motioned
him to come up.
And when he got there,
he punched him.
INTERVIEWER: That's a
little bit shocking.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah.
They didn't have HR departments
in those days.
INTERVIEWER: I'd assume not.
MICHAEL ROMANO: But
lesson learned.
INTERVIEWER: And so would you
say that's the craziest thing
that you've seen
at family meal?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Maybe--
in a negative way.
Many wonderful things
happen in terms of
the food that's created.
And sometimes family
meal is used--
there are special moments when
someone may be having a
birthday, or someone may be
leaving, or-- just as we saw
the other day--
at the Union Square Cafe, a
celebration of someone, in
this case, who had completed
25 years at the restaurant.
DANNY MEYER: As the bartender.
MICHAEL ROMANO: As
the bartender.
INTERVIEWER: Wow.
MICHAEL ROMANO: So those
are occasions--
just as in a family, where you
want to do something a little
special and celebrate that.
DANNY MEYER: I also think that,
just as in a family,
it's not always smooth
sailing.
There are arguments.
Sometimes they are debates.
Sometimes they're
disagreements.
But just because you're having
those kind of disagreements or
arguments, bringing them to a
table together actually, I
think, heightens the possibility
that something
good might come of it.
And I'm very, very impressed.
We just got a tour of your
family table upstairs.
The difference is yours is so
large that not everyone is
eating together at the
exact same time.
But nonetheless, you're taking
time from your day to sit down
and be together.
And I think especially in a
world that you are doing more
than anyone to help to create,
where people spend time with a
device rather than face-to-face
with somebody
else, the table over which
conversation can be had with
food and drink is one of the
last places in our lives that
really bring human
beings together.
And we think they crave
it even more.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Right.
I guess eating is, and hopefully
will remain,
something you can't
do virtually.
You have to actually sit down
and put food in your mouth.
DANNY MEYER: You know what-- one
thing I want to make sure
you guys do not invent at Google
is the notion that one
of these 3D printers can make a
steak medium rare and juicy.
As long as you don't do that,
we're in good shape.
INTERVIEWER: OK, fair enough.
I'll talk to the people
upstairs about that.
And so I know that sometimes
becoming a family at a
restaurant is quite literal.
Danny, I know you met your
wife at a restaurant.
She was actually the
waitress there.
So is that what we're
all doing wrong?
Do we need to start working
front of house to find love?
How common is that?
DANNY MEYER: My bet is
it's happening right
under your nose here.
You just don't know about it.
But I'll never forget when Union
Square Cafe first opened
in 1985, a long time ago,
I couldn't find
the chef one night.
And I looked high and low--
it was before Michael
was there.
Michael was cooking at a French
restaurant at the time.
I looked in the kitchen.
He wasn't there.
Looked at the dishwasher
station.
He wasn't there.
Looked everywhere.
And finally, there was only one
door I hadn't opened, and
that was the walk-in
refrigerator in the basement.
And there he was, making out
with the sous chef in front of
the oyster bin.
And I said, oh boy, this is
going to be interesting.
And I called my dad.
And I said, what do I do?
I had never run a
business before.
And he said, you know, as far as
I'm concerned, restaurants
are a lot like families.
And he said, they're like
extended families.
And the number of intense
hours people are working
together, they're either going
to fight or they're going to
fall in love.
And as far as I'm concerned, you
got the better option of
the two here.
So we've had so many people
fall in love, have babies.
We could do a whole family
tree of all of our
restaurants.
We could probably start three
new restaurants just with the
offspring of people.
INTERVIEWER: I was about to
say, a second generation--
you've got to bring them,
train them young.
DANNY MEYER: Absolutely.
MICHAEL ROMANO: That didn't
happen at the French
restaurant I was working at,
because there were no women
working there.
DANNY MEYER: That's
a good point.
It used to be thought that--
MICHAEL ROMANO: Well, I don't
know if it was a good point.
DANNY MEYER: It was
a bad point, but
you make a good point.
You see, it's like a family.
We--
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah.
That was one of the great things
about coming to Union
Square Cafe from that
French restaurant.
It was a whole new world opening
up, and there were men
and women working in
the restaurant.
And it was a whole different
atmosphere, a whole way of
approaching the business in a
much more open, embracing
people, accepting people.
It was more challenging in a
way, because it was about
really dealing with people as
individuals and their needs.
And it was, as you say,
hospitality--
engaging with the person
in a dialogue--
as opposed to, I'm the chef,
do it my way, and just shut
up, which is the old-school
way of approaching it.
INTERVIEWER: Well, and clearly,
you two talk as if
you're family.
And I know that you've known
each other for 30 years.
So how did you first meet?
MICHAEL ROMANO: The same
place he met his wife.
INTERVIEWER: Clearly a great
restaurant for you.
DANNY MEYER: It was a seafood
restaurant on 22nd Street that
was called Pesca.
I think it was actually a little
bit ahead of its time.
It was San Francisco, a
little bit Italian.
It was a really good
restaurant.
And they ended up going out of
business at a certain point.
It then became Bolo,
under Bobby Flay.
And now it's a wreck-ball
site.
There's nothing there.
It's kind of sad.
But that was my first
restaurant job.
And I'll never forget, there
came a day when-- in addition
to Pesca's chef, a
guy named Skip--
there was this new guy
who had just been
brought in from France.
And none of us knew why
he was there, but--
MICHAEL ROMANO: Including me.
DANNY MEYER: But he
was clearly cut
from a different cloth.
He was all buttoned up, whereas
everybody else was
kind of slouching.
And he wore one of these
fancy white kerchiefs.
He looked like a Boy Scout,
almost, with his
little white kerchief.
And then he would leave the
restaurant wearing Armani
suits, which we didn't even know
what that was in 1984.
And actually, I was so impressed
with Michael's work
that I begged the owner of the
restaurant to let me move to
the kitchen, because I had been
the lunch maitre d', or
the lunch assistant manager.
And we got to know each other.
I got to--
I don't think they gave
me very many jobs.
I got to snip the faces off
of soft-shell crabs.
INTERVIEWER: All the glamorous
work, clearly.
DANNY MEYER: Saute
a couple things.
Finally graduated me to
the risotto station--
the risotto al mare,
I remember that.
But anyway, then he was gone.
All of a sudden, he
was just gone.
And I had no idea
where he went.
Where'd you go?
MICHAEL ROMANO: La Caravelle.
DANNY MEYER: Oh, La Caravelle,
that's right.
And we stayed in touch.
Michael became famous because
not only was he a really good
chef, but he was the first young
American chef ever hired
at one of the fancy midtown
French restaurants.
And back then, all the good
restaurants, or all the
restaurants that were taken
seriously in New York-- this
is going to sound crazy
to you guys--
but they were all in midtown.
And they all started
with le, la, or il.
Every single one, because we
didn't trust that Americans
really knew how to
cook that well.
[?
INTERVIEWER: Didn't
know what they ?]
[? were doing. ?]
I know you mentioned
him wearing suits.
Is that a tradition that
you still continue?
Because you used to say, early
on in your career--
MICHAEL ROMANO: I loosened
up a bit,
because coming from the--
DANNY MEYER: What did
you used to say?
What did he used to say?
INTERVIEWER: That every
day you would come
in wearing a suit.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah,
definitely.
Well, because at
La Caravelle--
again, the midtown French--
that was sort of the dress
code of the restaurant.
And that's how our
guests dressed.
And it was appropriate, and
the owners felt it was
appropriate to dress
the same way.
And yeah, it used to
get a little crazy.
Because I would go in for
the morning service,
change into my whites.
And then after the morning
service, change back into the
suit, go out and maybe go to
the gym or do something.
And come back, change
again, and then
leave and change again.
It was a lot of changing.
INTERVIEWER: And you don't see
many chefs in suits, I feel,
these days.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Well,
times have changed.
INTERVIEWER: Right.
So can you remember the first
family meal that you guys
shared together?
MICHAEL ROMANO: It's
probably Pesca.
DANNY MEYER: I think
it was at Pesca.
And I was just telling
somebody this
story the other day.
But that was a really hard time,
because that was when we
were first learning
about AIDS.
This was in 1984.
We had never heard about
this illness before.
And one of the servers at the
restaurant had been sick with
something mysterious.
He was losing weight
like crazy.
He was breaking out in a way
no one had ever seen.
And he would come back
and work for a while.
And then he would leave.
No one had any idea
what it was.
But it was at family meal where
we learned about it.
It was hard, because one of the
things that does happen at
family meal is that the chef or
the sous chef prepares the
specials for that day.
And the whole staff
tastes them.
So that when you come to the
restaurant and you say, so
what do you recommend,
the waiter can
have an informed answer.
And that was the meal where we
were told that that was going
to stop happening.
There's no more sharing.
Back then, we would all take the
exact same fork and just
pass it around.
And that was one of the family
meals I remember most.
The other one I remember most
was the first time that I had
ever had a job where we were
allowed to drink wine before
going to work.
And I thought that
was pretty cool.
INTERVIEWER: I think
we'd all agree.
DANNY MEYER: And we would do
wine tastings together.
And that became a hallmark of
how we did our training at
Union Square Cafe.
But that's something that I
think we both learned at
various times.
I only cooked in France for
about three months.
Michael cooked there for about
three years, and Switzerland.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Six
years, yeah.
DANNY MEYER: Six years.
But there was never a family
meal in France where the staff
didn't sit down together, and
not only have their food
before you would come into the
restaurant, but we'd actually
have a glass of wine together.
And everybody trusted it.
Nobody was abusing the system.
It was good.
MICHAEL ROMANO: I remember one
place I worked in France where
there was a young chef, very,
very talented, but a little
impetuous and headstrong.
And he would come in--
I'd be having a chamomile
tea in the morning-- the
morning, this is.
And he'd come over to my station
and dump out the tea,
and pour in white
wine in the cup.
He was like, get to work.
I said, OK.
INTERVIEWER: So over the course
of the past 30 years,
what would you both say are
some of the best and worst
parts about working
with each other?
DANNY MEYER: Come on.
INTERVIEWER: You can just
say positive things.
DANNY MEYER: That wasn't part
of our contract, that we had
to talk about that.
INTERVIEWER: Family question.
DANNY MEYER: I'm going
to go with the best.
He can talk about the worst.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Should
I leave?
DANNY MEYER: No, the best
part, I think, were that
almost every single year--
keep in mind, we had one
restaurant, Union Square Cafe,
for the first 10 years.
So it hasn't really till the
last period of time that we've
been expanding.
Gramercy Tavern was our second
restaurant after 10 years.
And then there was Eleven
Madison Park and Tabla, and
Blue Smoke, and Maialino and
Shake Shack, and the Modern,
North End Grill.
INTERVIEWER: Catch a breath.
DANNY MEYER: Now Creative
Juice, which we're very
excited about.
I saw them pouring their
juice upstairs.
So that was good to see.
But anyway, during those
first 10 years--
same number of hours in the day,
but we just spent a whole
lot more of them together.
And we would go on a lot of
culinary expeditions.
It could be in Italy.
It could be France.
It could be parts
of this country.
And the most fun would be
to just go get ideas.
And keep in mind, guys, this
was way before Google.
And it was way before
things like GPS.
So if you wanted to go
discover a new idea--
which you need to do for
your restaurants--
you would really do the
old-fashioned kind of sleuth
work, which was meeting the
right people, asking the right
questions, turning over
the right rocks.
And you would find your way to
some out-of-the-way bistro in
the countryside of France, or
trattoria in the countryside
outside of Bologna, let's say.
And you would take your Michelin
map and do the best
you could to find these little
roads that barely even existed
on the best map in the world.
And by doing that work a little
harder than anyone else
did, we could often discover
dishes that no one had seen in
New York City.
And we could bring them back
here together, serve them at
Union Square Cafe.
And we would have a two-year
runway before--
and people would love it--
before anyone would copy it.
Today, that's so hard, because
by the time we find a place,
it's already been
photographed.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Remember panna
cotta in Piedmont?
DANNY MEYER: Of course I do.
MICHAEL ROMANO: No, I mean that
fits the description of
what you're saying.
DANNY MEYER: Yeah, I remember
the restaurant where we had
it, in La Morra.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah, it
was mind-boggling.
Just this incredible--
and panna cotta has become
the quiche of--
DANNY MEYER: And do you
remember the pollo al
lambrusco with the frittata
with the balsamico and--
MICHAEL ROMANO: I'm
getting hungry.
INTERVIEWER: You guys all
ate lunch already.
DANNY MEYER: Those were
the best times.
And for me, the best day ever
was we were going to try to do
a French version of
Union Square Cafe.
That's kind of how Eleven
Madison Park started off.
It was going to be a bistro
brasserie, but not too fancy.
That was how Eleven Madison
got its start.
And so we went to Paris.
And the very first day, right
off the airplane, we ate six
Michelin stars--
two three-star restaurants
in a row.
And my favorite part was you
were knocked out by the time
we got to dessert.
And we had five bistros
to hit the next day.
MICHAEL ROMANO: The jet
lag and fois gras
together, it's just--
INTERVIEWER: As long as your
head didn't land up in the
plate, I think that's fine.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Deadly,
deadly combination.
INTERVIEWER: And then so what
about your parents?
Were they encouraging of
this career choice?
Obviously, it's worked out
for you both, but--
MICHAEL ROMANO: No, my parents
were not thrilled when I told
them I was quitting--
I had gotten through two years
of regular college at Fordham.
And I was working at a
restaurant, Serendipity, on
the east side there-- which
is still there.
It's amazing.
And the owners of that
restaurant introduced me to
James Beard, who gave me that
little bit of encouragement to
pursue this.
He said, if you really like
cooking, why don't you do it
as a career, go to school,
learn how to do it?
So I quit college and
enrolled in a--
and the City University had--
has, still--
a hotel and restaurant
program.
My parents were not thrilled
to hear that I was quitting
college, because it was their
dream to have their children--
my sister and myself--
go to college.
But it was the right thing.
It really was the right thing.
Once I got into that school
and started learning about
cooking in a professional way
and running a restaurant, I
was so happy.
It felt like this is what
I really want to do.
And I did very well at
it, because I could
really apply myself.
And school had become
such a drag.
I was really not enjoying it.
But this was wonderful.
INTERVIEWER: Danny,
what about you?
DANNY MEYER: Well, I don't think
anyone in my particular
generation who had gotten a
liberal arts degree was even
remotely thinking about going
into the restaurant business.
It was just way before
Food TV.
Dining out has really become
a spectator sport.
And it's something that--
I think we've gotten
really lucky.
I think we were born
at the right time.
People reserved really
good food for
anniversaries and birthdays.
And on the other occasions, they
went to a bar or a pub,
or just the local restaurant.
But it wasn't something that
people pursued and followed
and took pictures of.
Forget tweeting and OpenTable
and all that kind of stuff.
It just didn't exist.
So it was completely not
something that I thought I was
going to do.
But I just feel so lucky
to have done it.
I had been thinking about
becoming a lawyer.
And it was on the eve of taking
my LSATs that I freaked
out over dinner.
I was with my aunt and uncle
and a grandmother.
And I couldn't drink wine.
I couldn't eat a lot of food,
because I was so nervous about
the next morning.
And my uncle basically--
so it actually was someone
in my family that
caused this to happen.
And when he asked me what was
bothering me, I said, because
I'm taking my LSATs.
And he said, well, you do want
to be a lawyer, don't you?
And I said, no.
And he basically dropped
his fork.
And he said, you know, you're
going to be dead forever.
Why in the world would you do
something that you don't love
during these few moments
that you're alive?
And I said, because I don't know
what else to do with my
political science degree.
And he said, that's the
stupidest answer I've ever
heard in my life.
And I said, well, what
should I do?
And he said, are you kidding?
I mean, all I've ever heard
you talk about is
restaurants and food.
And I said, should I go
eat in restaurants
the rest of my life?
It still didn't dawn on me that
this was a viable kind of
career path.
He gave me a hard time.
He said, I'm not talking to you
again until you answer the
question the right way.
And literally, I took the LSATs
that Saturday morning,
never applied.
And it was the Monday thereafter
that I called one
of my buddies from college and
said, let's go to restaurant
school together.
And he made the mistake of
telling his dad, who said,
over my dead body.
And his dad sent him
to business school.
We're still good friends,
but he got out.
But he did introduce me--
he was in a bank training
program.
And he introduced me to--
back then, banks would never
lend money to restaurants.
But their bank, US Trust,
had exactly one
restaurant client, Pesca.
And my friend said, the least
I can do is to introduce you
to our one restaurant client.
They're really nice people,
and I can get you
an interview there.
And I got the interview, which
consisted of being looked up
and down, and the owner
said, he'll do.
That was, again, before
HR departments.
And if it had not been for
taking the LSATs, the next day
calling the guy I called, and
him feeling bad but hooking me
up with that one restaurant--
I never would be in
this industry.
I never would have met him.
I never would have
met my wife.
So just for me, it's a great
lesson that every day we get
presented with these incredible
options that you
didn't even know were going to
present themselves to you.
And in each case, if you really
go with your gut and
your passion, it's just
remarkable as you look back
over time how your
life can change.
INTERVIEWER: Absolutely.
Well, I think we're all glad
that it worked out.
MICHAEL ROMANO: I want
to go back a second.
I never got to answer that.
DANNY MEYER: Yeah, Michael's
not glad it worked out, so
he's going to tell you what
he hates about me.
MICHAEL ROMANO: No.
No, like you, I will say what
was great about it, and--
DANNY MEYER: But?
MICHAEL ROMANO: No, it was
coming to Union Square Cafe.
So I had already had I don't
know how many years of
experience in the business.
And talked with Danny, and
persuaded me to come to this
downtown place that was not what
I thought was my career
path, which was the
classic French.
But once there, I think the best
thing was watching Danny,
who was very inexperienced
at this thing, but really
passionate about it.
DANNY MEYER: I was very--
MICHAEL ROMANO: And learning and
creating and growing, and
what we have now--
our restaurant group.
And not only the physical
places, but the ideas, the
philosophy that are very
important, and I
think really beautiful.
Watching that spark ignite
in you and develop
was really the best.
I mean, the trips were wonderful
and all that.
But this whole idea of watching
this just blossom was
an amazing process.
And it's still going on.
DANNY MEYER: And that's a
philosophy we call enlightened
hospitality, which I
know is pretty--
what we call it is just
what we call it.
But I think it's how you guys
run your company, which is
basically saying, no business
in the world is different in
terms of the stakeholders.
We all have the exact same five
stakeholders, but in what
order are you going to
prioritize them?
And I think "family meal" is
actually a great expression of
saying, if you really want the
best outcome, you've got to
start with yourself.
You've got to take care of
your own team first, even
before you put your
guests second.
And the notion of putting your
customers second was certainly
not anything we were
taught about.
And the notion of putting your
investors fifth, after your
employees, after your customers,
after your
community, after your suppliers,
and really
believing that by virtue of
doing it that way, you create
a virtuous cycle.
And you can make more money if
you put your investors fifth.
And you can make more customers
happy if you put
your customer second--
is what we've developed
over time.
Now just quickly, I thought
Michael was going to say the
worst thing, which
was that in the--
it took me eight months, even
though we knew each other, to
convince him to leave this
fancy-schmancy French
restaurant on 55th Street.
It was a great restaurant.
I don't blame him for not
wanting to leave.
But come on, Union
Square Cafe?
INTERVIEWER: Didn't have a le
or an il in front of it.
DANNY MEYER: And finally-- yeah,
I was even willing to
call it Il Union Square
if that would help.
I was even going to
change the name.
But anyway, finally, after about
month six, I convinced
him to at least come downtown
and experience the restaurant
just as a guest.
OK, don't take my word
for it, Michael.
Just see it.
And so he brings in
three people.
They're a table for four.
And--
do you remember what
happened there?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah.
DANNY MEYER: On that night?
And of course, I'm very nervous,
because my whole
future is hinging upon
this one meal here.
MICHAEL ROMANO: And Danny was
very generous and brought over
four complimentary glasses
of champagne on a tray.
He himself was in the dining
room, carrying the tray with
the four glasses of champagne,
which he proceeded
to drop on my lap.
DANNY MEYER: And not only did
the champagne spill, but one
of the glasses shattered
all over Michael's lap.
So obviously, he has a very
good sense of humor.
INTERVIEWER: It was
a memorable start.
MICHAEL ROMANO: It
was a good start.
A good omen.
INTERVIEWER: So 30 years
now, third cookbook.
Whose idea was it to create
the "Family Table"?
DANNY MEYER: 27 and 1/2 years.
Just want to-- don't push us.
INTERVIEWER: Nearly 30 years.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Well, the
coauthor, Karen Stabiner,
whose daughter works in our
company, and was a fairly
regular diner at our company--
observed something we
knew very well.
That every day, twice a day, our
entire staff sits down to
meals that are prepared by the
cooks, for the cooks and the
dining room.
And she had a conversation
with us.
And we thought there could be
something wonderful in this,
in presenting not
only the food--
the recipes of what's being
prepared-- but also the
stories to celebrate the
people who animate our
restaurants, who are the
lifeblood of our restaurants.
Because there's so many
wonderful stories about--
some of them have been
there 25 years.
And in that time, people assume
certain roles, some
iconic roles, that become
very important--
just like in a family--
to the smooth running
of the operation.
And they're the people who bring
in the new people and
show them what to do
and what not to do.
And it's important that they're
like the anchors that
hold the history of the
place together.
So as we got into the work a
little bit more, it became
very, very interesting.
Because one of the big
challenges for me, unlike the
first two books we did,
those were my recipes.
Those were recipes we were
serving in the Union Square
Cafe that were tried and true.
It was just a matter of
selecting them and then
getting them to the home size.
These were not my recipes.
These were recipes that the
cooks were making for
themselves.
And in fact, there
was no recipe.
They were just throwing
stuff together.
DANNY MEYER: They would just go
raid the refrigerator for
the items that--
when you're cooking, there's
always stuff that you
butchered on the side, or the
leaves of something where you
used the part of the fruit
or the vegetable.
MICHAEL ROMANO: They come
up with dishes.
DANNY MEYER: These
guys are amazing.
They have lots and lots
of really good
ingredients to cook with.
They have only a little bit of
time to do it, because they're
spending so much time
preparing for
when you come in.
And they've got to come up
with something that's
economical, quick, and can be
done in large portions.
And what they tend to do--
MICHAEL ROMANO: And delicious.
DANNY MEYER: And delicious.
Because they're cooking for each
other, and they're going
to get immediate feedback.
And they want to take
care of each other.
And what's amazing about
it is they also draw--
unlike in the restaurant, where
we're trying to create
food that's going to feel like,
this is something I
never could have done at home,
that's why I like going there.
You don't just go there
because we're
going to do your dishes.
These cooks are cooking things
from their home.
And so through this book, you're
going to find all kinds
of ethnic touches.
Because if you give some really
good beef to this guy,
and he's from the Dominican
Republic, this is what you're
going to get.
If you give that same beef to
somebody from Texas, you're
going to get something
completely different.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Or Korea.
DANNY MEYER: Or Korea or
Ecuador or Colombia.
And so what's fun about this
book is that the only
through-line is this is food
from the heart, from people
who go to work for the purpose
of taking care of people.
INTERVIEWER: What I thought was
really interesting about
the book is it's not just
the high-profile chefs--
who are part of Union Square
Hospitality Group, that you
hear about so often--
it's a lot of behind-the-scenes
stories.
It's a lot of people you might
never see front of house.
So how intentional was that
decision to kind of highlight
them in the photographs
and the stories?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Completely
intentional.
We did ask the chefs--
again, who do not cook the
family meal-- to contribute
recipes that they might cook
for their families or have
cooked for them.
The best recipe in the book
is my mother's lasagna.
And that's how that
got in there.
DANNY MEYER: According to you.
MICHAEL ROMANO: According
to me, that's right.
DANNY MEYER: I kind of
like our family's
roast asparagus with--
anyway.
But--
INTERVIEWER: You get the book,
you can check both out and
then inform us who
the winner is.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Or serve
one with the other.
But yeah, it's definitely about
the cooks making this,
not about the high-profile
chefs.
INTERVIEWER: And so do dishes
from family meal ever make it
to the restaurant?
I know I've heard a lot about
the Dominican beef.
MICHAEL ROMANO: That has.
It's a dish that Victor's been
making for a long time, as
long as I can remember.
And every time he makes
it, I'm so delighted.
And now the current chef, Carmen
Quagliata, who's the
brilliant chef at Union
Square Cafe--
he put it on the branch menu.
DANNY MEYER: And we've had
that happen at Maialino.
Our breakfast cook--
or he was our breakfast cook.
Now he's at Gramercy Terrace--
who we lovingly call Hoss.
He's from New Orleans
originally, or
somewhere in Louisiana.
And he would make these
ham-studded biscuits, which
don't exactly go with a Roman
trattoria, but that's fine.
Because for family meals, same
thing-- that's where I'm from.
I've got some ends of the
prosciutto that we couldn't
slice when you guys come in.
And they were awesome.
And he would pour maple
syrup all over them.
And we sell those now.
We make a lot of money.
INTERVIEWER: So how would you
say from a technological
standpoint advances have changed
the way that you
approach making cookbooks,
from your first till now?
Be it photography or--
DANNY MEYER: That's such
a good question.
At the end of the day, I think
a cookbook author has to make
a huge number--
the first decision you have
to make irrespective of
technology or photography
is this.
What's the point of
this cookbook?
Is this a marketing tool slash
souvenir for the restaurant
that, while beautiful, will
never be cooked from?
In other words, is this a book
that we hope might live on
your living room coffee table?
Or do we hope this is a book
that you'll actually get olive
oil all over the pages, and rip
out the pages, because you
can't stop using it?
And I would say that more often
than not, we have sided
on the "we want people to
use it." Our books are--
I hope you'll find that
it's not unattractive.
But my bet is that this is not
going to be stacked up with
the French Laundry and Eleven
Madison Park, which are
gorgeous, gorgeous cookbooks.
I think this is one that you're
going to cook from.
And so I think that the
technology, to a degree that
that's important, is
that you can--
I think the only thing that I
think about technology-wise is
that everything's
done on ebooks.
But I'm still not sure
that that works
as well for a cookbook.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah, but in
the making of the book.
Other than obviously the
advances in photography--
digital photography-- but other
than that, it feels
pretty much about the same.
Doing this book and the first
book, which came out in '94--
I don't know that it
was much different.
DANNY MEYER: And at the end of
the day, what matters more
than anything is, did you
test the recipes?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Right.
DANNY MEYER: Because--
MICHAEL ROMANO: And
that's the same.
DANNY MEYER: --as I said, we
don't think we have the
capability of producing
a gorgeous book.
So since we know that's not our
greatest strength, what we
do rely on is what we
think our greater
strength is, is we want--
if you cook, we want you
to feel like a winner.
If you're going to go to the
trouble of buying the
ingredients and prepping them
in your own kitchen, we want
you say, that was a really
good use of my time.
And the way that's going to
happen is that both you and
the people you're cooking
for say, that was yummy.
Where'd you get that recipe?
And that's what we want
to have happen.
We actually delayed this book
for six months, because we
were not as thrilled as we
wanted to be with these dishes
tasting exactly like they tasted
when they were cooked
for family meal.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Right.
Because it was a question of
really developing the recipe.
DANNY MEYER: Just
had to be tested
and tested and retested.
MICHAEL ROMANO: And you have to
be careful with using too
much high-tech equipment
in testing.
As a matter of fact, we want
to test not on our
professional ranges and things,
but on something akin
to what most folks
have at home.
Because otherwise, it could
change the recipe.
DANNY MEYER: And our recipe
tester shops for the
ingredients in regular
markets.
We don't just take them
from our restaurants.
Because again, if it can't be
done with the market that you
go to, whether it's a
greenmarket or a supermarket,
then it may not taste right.
Then the other thing that we
really try to encourage people
is it's like a piece of music.
This is how the music
was written.
Try to play it, and then make
it yours thereafter.
So Michael doesn't actually stop
in your home and check to
see if you're doing it right.
MICHAEL ROMANO: We could
arrange that.
INTERVIEWER: Yeah, we wish.
I think there'd be a long
line for that sign-up.
So we're about to take some
audience questions.
There are two microphones, if
you guys want to line up.
And before we do, just to give
you a chance to ask them, we
have a couple
fill-in-the-blanks.
So the most challenging
part of my job is--
DANNY MEYER: I have not yet
succeeded at adding more than
24 hours to a day.
INTERVIEWER: When you
do, let us all know.
MICHAEL ROMANO: I guess coming
up with new ideas, keeping
things fresh, keeping things
with the times.
INTERVIEWER: And if I weren't in
this industry, I would be--
DANNY MEYER: A cookbook
author.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Maybe in
the music business.
INTERVIEWER: I hate it
when I get asked--
hopefully, it's nothing
I asked, but--
DANNY MEYER: What if it is?
INTERVIEWER: That's fine.
I can take it.
MICHAEL ROMANO: What's
your favorite
restaurant in New York?
DANNY MEYER: Why did you
go into this business?
I'm sorry.
I just--
I wish I really knew.
I wish I knew.
I think the answer-- and it
actually gives me another
chance to answer the question,
because it's not my story.
It's the fact that we all have
something inside of us that,
if we just listen to
it, there it is.
And the reason that I don't like
the question is that I
always end up answering it based
on my story, when it's
really just everybody's story,
which is just listen to what's
telling you is there.
INTERVIEWER: In my fridge,
I always have--
MICHAEL ROMANO: Japanese
condiments.
DANNY MEYER: Really?
Mayonnaise.
INTERVIEWER: My hangover
cure is--
DANNY MEYER: Another drink.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Not getting
out of bed.
INTERVIEWER: The secret
to Shack's sauce is--
DANNY MEYER: Untold.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Will
remain a secret.
INTERVIEWER: OK, I thought I'd
get you guys with that one.
At least we tried.
Lastly, my greatest food
indulgence is--
MICHAEL ROMANO: Actually the
secret is it tastes good.
DANNY MEYER: Sausage
and mushroom
pizza from almost anywhere.
I have my favorites.
But you tell me we're going to
have sausage and mushroom
pizza, I'm there.
INTERVIEWER: OK, so I think
we've got our first question.
AUDIENCE: So I like cooking, but
it's hard to compete with
the chefs at Google.
So I cook on weekends, and
I have friends over.
But my trouble that I have with
following recipes is that
they say, buy a bunch
of stuff--
some of which I have, some
of which I don't--
and then I'm not going to cook
until the next week.
So what I'd really like to do is
be able to say, I have this
stuff that's sitting
around the kitchen.
What can I make with it?
And I'm wondering if you have
given thought to addressing
for this ingredient here, are
things that you can do with
it, rather than saying,
make this dish?
MICHAEL ROMANO: That's an
idea for another book.
DANNY MEYER: No.
Michael just said, that's a
great idea for another book.
I do think, though, that given
what you're concerned about,
that this book here is--
it's actually exactly what our
cooks are faced with is the
exact same thing you're
faced with.
They don't get to go out
shopping in order--
they don't get to call the
purveyor and order stuff for
family meal.
They're looking in
the refrigerator.
the cupboard.
And they're saying, how can
I do a balanced meal?
Something green, something
starchy, something protein,
something whatever
it happens to be.
Because we really cover
the whole gamut--
not to the degree you guys
do upstairs, perhaps.
But it's based on what
we have on hand.
So what I would say,
you can reverse
engineer this cookbook.
You can probably reverse
engineer a lot of cookbooks.
And look at what you have
in your refrigerator.
And then look in the
ingredients--
look in the index
of the cookbook.
I'm pretty sure you're
not going to find
too many wacky things.
What I get frustrated about is
a recipe that forces me to go
buy something.
And I use a tiny bit.
And the rest either sits on the
inside of my refrigerator
door shelving or in the cabinet
for the next three
years till it gets green on
the edges or something.
MICHAEL ROMANO: And also, as
you reverse engineer the
recipe, if you have ingredients
that you have left
over, if you look at
another recipe that
attracts your attention.
And it might not have that
ingredient, but an ingredient
that is similar and
texture or form.
And cooking time--
I'll give an example.
If you've used celery, and
you've got celery left over.
And there's something that
calls for fennel.
Use the celery, you know what
I mean, as a substitute.
Play around with it.
And you can use up
what you have.
It's a good practice to
go through and you
use up what you have.
DANNY MEYER: Learning to
liberate yourself, also.
If a recipe calls for kale, and
all you have is spinach--
MICHAEL ROMANO: Or chard
or something.
DANNY MEYER: Yeah, but just use
your head, and say, all
right, it's not the end of the
world if I put in spinach.
But spinach is a lot more
tender than kale.
So if there's a cooking element
to it, you're not
going to cook it as much.
It's not rocket science,
this stuff.
Seriously, just look at this as
a starting point of flavors
that go together that
make people happy.
As opposed to a science
experiment that, if you don't
get it perfectly, it's going
to lead to unhappiness.
AUDIENCE: So my question is
along those lines, and along
one of the last ones
you were asked.
So I have a stack of
cooking books.
And I now have a new baby.
And I do cook almost
every night.
And I find myself more and
more using a tablet and
searching on the internet and
putting things together based
on that, because going to the
cookbook is just hard.
And I don't think
I'm alone there.
So the question is, what
would the cookbook of
the future look like?
And along the lines of this
question is-- and what you
suggested is--
could you make it more dynamic
in the sense that you could
have a recipe that kind of
evolves with based on what you
have, and the time you
have, and so on?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Yeah, it might
be a way to plug in the
ingredients you have, and then
have that generate a recipe,
or lead you to an recipe.
Do an existing one.
Yeah, that would be cool.
AUDIENCE: And how do
you pay for that?
Because right, there is
intellectual property.
Right now, people post recipes
on the internet.
And you have to validate them,
as opposed to having some
validation that came from
some authority.
And so?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Well, when the
book goes out, it's open for
the public to use, including
other restaurants.
But that's an interesting
point.
DANNY MEYER: You asked, what
does the cookbook of the
future look like?
I've heard for years--
and I haven't seen it yet-- but
in the same way that it's
really hard to find a
kitchen that doesn't
have a microwave oven--
your kitchen doesn't
have one, does it?
MICHAEL ROMANO: It does.
DANNY MEYER: All right,
even his kitchen
has a microwave oven--
that people have said that the
tablets will become ubiquitous
with sort of temperature-proof
fronts.
And it'll actually be on your
kitchen wall for the purpose
of being able to look
up recipes.
And there's so many recipes
online right now.
In fact, there are websites--
I forget the name of it--
that have gotten hundreds and
hundreds of cookbook authors
to agree to just give it away,
in the hope that, if someone
likes the one or two recipes
that are on the website, that
they'll then follow up.
I guess kind of like a Pandora
version of cookbooks--
that they'll then go buy the
cookbook thereafter.
But we haven't done
that ourselves.
MICHAEL ROMANO: No, but it's
an interesting prospect.
Just plugging in ingredients,
and having recipes come up.
You guys could do that.
Figure out a way to
make that happen.
INTERVIEWER: We have time
for two more questions.
AUDIENCE: So one of the things
that I love-- and I'm sure
many other people love-- about
Shake Shack, particularly the
park location--
is that there's the
web camera, and
you can see the line.
And I think that's like--
being here, that you're at
Google is something that I
think is just very
forward-looking when it came
out, I don't know how
many years ago, that
functionality came out.
But it's just amazing, that sort
of marriage of technology
and just using it in
a way that's not
necessarily in your face.
I would just like to hear your
thoughts about what you think
may be the next step of how
you might integrate
technology.
Maybe not just at Shake Shack,
but some far in the future
restaurant, or maybe the
next restaurant.
And what you think might be sort
of the next game-changing
implementation of maybe
something more technological
in your restaurants.
Knowing that that's
not your focus, of
course, but just an idea.
DANNY MEYER: Well, I'm glad
you like the Shack cam.
And as recently as last week,
we had a discussion as to
whether we should do more
of them with the
different Shake Shacks.
And so far, we've decided
not to, just because--
I don't know.
We don't want to be
in your face.
But what I could imagine in
our business, as being the
next frontier for us, I think
has to do with how you pay in
the restaurants.
And I know Starbucks has
invested in the Square, which
allows you to pay without--
if it's going to work for
Starbucks to save time and to
capture information, you can
only imagine how much time you
could save instead of expecting
and hoping that your
server in a restaurant knows
exactly when it is that you
want to go, and exactly
when you're done.
And I think the opportunity for
us to custom-make more of
your experience based on
what you like exists.
And it's somewhere--
we've made a lot of headway
over the last decade and a
half with things like OpenTable
that allow you to
reserve whenever you
want to reserve.
But also from our end, allows us
to capture more information
about how often you come to
which of our restaurants,
where you like to sit, who your
favorite waiter is, what
your dietary preferences are.
What we haven't done a great job
of is sort of putting that
together with giving you the
power to determine more about
what happens inside of your
experience itself.
We, to a degree, believe that
high tech and high touch can
help each other.
But we're still much more in
the high touch camp when it
comes to the actual restaurant
experience.
So if you want to send us any
good ideas, you should know
that we're aware.
We know that there's something
else there.
But getting back to "Family
Table," we just don't want to
lose the sense that--
we're happy that you come in
with your camera, and you
Instagram something
that you loved.
We think that 95% of the
pictures being taken are to
tell someone else about
something you liked.
So we like that technology is
entering the experience.
But we still kind of hope that
for that time you're at the
restaurant, it's the time that
you are still with the person
you're with.
And not only doing this
the whole time, so.
MICHAEL ROMANO: That's
a good question.
AUDIENCE: As a team of
coauthors, I would be so
interested to know what your
process was like for writing
the book, from idea generation
to development to getting it
all down, and any surprises
along the way.
And kind of whether you guys
had roles that became more
fixed, or if they overlapped,
and kind of
how that all worked.
DANNY MEYER: Can I just go first
and say, I'm not the
coauthor of this book.
We have coauthored
books together.
But Michael's coauthor
was Karen Stabiner.
All I did was write
the forward.
So I just want to be really
clear that, if you don't like
the recipes, it's not on me.
MICHAEL ROMANO: And that process
was pretty clearly
delineated.
Karen was the one who had the
sometimes thankless job of
going in and ascertaining
what--
once we had determined what were
the recipes we wanted to
include-- and that was done by
watching and participating in
the family meals throughout
all of our restaurants--
then the work had to begin to
sort of capture that recipe
from the cook.
And again, this is not an
established recipe that
someone is doing.
It's whatever is there that
day, the inspiration that
comes, a little of this,
a little of that.
But that little of this and that
had to be turned into 2
and 1/2 cups of this and
3 tablespoons of that.
And that's difficult, because
they're not cooking that way.
They're just throwing
stuff in.
So Karen did the initial
capture of, here's this
recipe, here's a rough idea of
what it's going to look like,
at which point I took over.
And we had to test it and then
make it work as a recipe.
And sometimes, that involved an
executive decision of like,
well, I'm not going to put that
much of that in there.
I'm going to put a little
of this in here.
But by and large, we remained
very true to what the initial
recipe was.
And then there was the part of
getting the stories, which was
a similar dynamic of
interviewing and talking to
people, and getting
that together.
And then it goes into the
photography, which I had to
work with the food stylist and
get the food to look right.
DANNY MEYER: And it took a long
time to figure out who
would be the right photographer,
because family
meal is not gorgeous
food by nature.
It's not.
INTERVIEWER: Doesn't it just
come looking like that, like
it does in the book?
DANNY MEYER: Well, no.
But the point is that if these
were gorgeous photographs, it
would lose a lot of the
authenticity that this is what
we put out on the fly
for each other.
MICHAEL ROMANO: No tweezers
used to put the--
DANNY MEYER: And so we had
to find just the right
photographer who could catch
people being people, and who
could catch food being food,
and the right stylist who
understood that a great stylist
wants to be known for
being a great stylist.
They don't want to be known for
just letting food be food.
And so that was an interesting
experience with this cookbook.
MICHAEL ROMANO: Right.
And all those choices along
the way have to happen.
AUDIENCE: Were there any big
surprises in the process?
MICHAEL ROMANO: Some.
For me, the surprises were
around recipes that had
difficulty getting to work, just
because they were so kind
of raw and inaccurate.
Or I had to make a decision
that, sometimes with the
chef's recipes, it was a little
beyond what I thought
should be included
in a family--
a little too, maybe too
precious, or it would have
wound up being too expensive.
And I'm very sure that that
chef making that dish-- it
would have turned out amazing.
But I wasn't so sure that it
could have worked in the
cookbook with the home cook.
So I had to edit, had to
veto certain things,
and make the selection.
So there were some
surprises there.
AUDIENCE: Thanks.
MICHAEL ROMANO: You're welcome
INTERVIEWER: Michael and Danny,
thank you so much for
taking time out of your
day to come visit.
DANNY MEYER: Thank you.
MICHAEL ROMANO: A pleasure.
[APPLAUSE]